gerade wird in berlin die groko fanden
sie sind hier bei mir ist das damit die
spd noch in ein gutes licht gerückt
werden kann oder muss ich das salz
privaten hilfeschrei deuten also
langweilig bei der bei den gefahren und
das zieht sich sein so ewig oder sogar
dass es einfach abwechslung sie sind ja
vize-chef also martin schulz ist der
chef dann sind sie der vize-chef was
passiert werden martin schulz
vizekanzler wird sind sie dann vize
vizekanzler oder nachgedacht aber das
hört sich gut an also wie viele personen
müssen aus dem weg geräumt werden dass
sie dann kanzler sind
ich glaube dass es dafür gleich noch
eine lebenserwartung nicht komfort her
hat ja was dich eigentlich bin ich
richtig den stimmungskanonen aber die
masse unterschätzen wir fangen sie
natürlich eigentlich auch keinen grund
zum gut drauf sein vielleicht kurzum die
situation aufzulockern
haben sie eigentlich schon mal daran
gedacht dass sie die jim henson company
verklagen könnten weil der muppet bieter
ist ja ganz klar an ihnen orientieren
sie also bei der helfer habe hätte ich
jetzt noch ein bisschen schwierig gelte
es natur braun was sie tragen aber ich
könnte mir darüber nachdenken ob ich das
mal versuchen mit diesen karten mit
dieser karotten farbe sie sind ja gerade
bei diesem nachwuchs also
familiennachzugs debatten sind sie
extrem jetzt in streit geraten mit
andreas scheuer von der csu sie an beide
laut gebrüllt als einziger richtig
brüllt sie sind nicht so einer der
einfach wenn jetzt andreas scheuer eine
brücke herunter springen wird nicht mit
springen oder also gut da würden sie
sich wahrscheinlich freuen ganz ehrlich
nicht wird glaube ich schon die 112
wählen aber das muss dann noch reichen
jetzt werden wir schon jetzt sagen
können csu hat gewonnen oder spd hat
gewonnen können wir ganz klar sagen wer
verloren hat nämlich die flüchtlinge und
deren familienangehörige was würden sie
denen jetzt sagen also wenn sie die
größen können wir haben immerhin
versucht möglichst viel herauszuholen
er geht mit denen nicht andererseits
gibt es im bundestag eine bessere
mehrheit
und jetzt haben sie sich über den tisch
ziehen lassen kann man das sagen bei den
familiennachzug rutschen lassen haben
wir uns nicht an weil er weniger
rausgekommen als vorher also schon ein
bisschen mehr herausgekommen aber ich
bin damit zufrieden sind sie nicht mehr
also die spd schaut mit einem lachenden
und einem lächerlichen auge in die
zukunft und vielleicht auch mit 2
ich habe aber lachtrainerin eingeladen
hallo ich bin ich probiere ich könnte
sie ich sage hallo herr stegner dann
können sie sagen hallo ich grüße sie
dann sagen schön dass sie da sind
herrscht gegner dann sagen sie mir auch
mal bitte schön dass sie da sind ja
wunder von musik hat und dann schütteln
wir die hände und land an
das läuft jetzt ein bauer schleife durch
reden
hallo ihr lächeln auf den vielen dank
für das schöne gespräch dann steht ja
okay meinte link
bis 11
[Applaus]